on le conseil du jour faut-il courir
seul ou en groupe ça déjà tout dépend de
votre caractère il ya des gens qui sont
très solitaire qui ont envie de gérer
leurs efforts comme il l'entend il faut
les laisser en revanche un petit
problème c'est que quand on commence la
course à pied ou n'importe quel sport et
bien si on est tout seul on fait des
erreurs on se positionne mal et là on
peut se blesser
ça vous ne le retrouverai pas puisque
vous aurez tous les conseils si jamais
vous décidez vous affiliés à un club et
c'est un des grands avantages de la
course en groupe
en plus de se faire des relations des
amis vous avez des conseils très bray
précieux pour ne pas vous blesser alors
c'est qu'il ya un effet masse et il ya
toujours des gens qui sont plus forts
que les autres on a envie de les suivre
et parfois et bien comme on dit dans le
jargon on se met dans le rouge et c'est
un petit peu plus dur alors ça c'est
davantage de la course en solitaire
c'est à dire que vous pouvez faire ce
que vous voulez quand vous voulez au
moment que vous décidez et au rythme que
vous voulez donc il ya des pour il ya
des comptes mais surtout pensez bien que
c'est un sport délicat la course à pied
il faut des conseils pour pas faire
n'importe quoi et je pense que pour
débuter il faut les conseils de gens
avisés et donc c'est dans les groupes ou
les clubs qu'on les trouve ensuite libre
à vous de vous entraîner tout seul à
bientôt pour d'autres conseils